Very good atmosphere at the European Commission
after the vote of the ppe
extremely mixed in favor of its
Ursula Vanderlien.
Thierry Breton melted away from a tweet
and the tweet was not
particularly sympathetic to its sanding and
President of the European Commission,
Ursula Vanderlaine.
So,
since Thierry Breton,
commissioner in the Vanderlaine commission,
explained that,
well
Oursula may no longer have been in position
to make 1/2 mandate insofar as it was very
very poorly elected by his own party.
Well then let's explain the subtext,
in fact,
1st point for,
under the sale,
Berliner is therefore a candidate for its reproduction,
but
there is nobody else and it is perhaps the only one
condition that could mean that it will indeed be
reappointed to the position of president of the commission.
Even though
even if officially
everyone agrees to say
that she has wonderfully
does the job,
that
basically,
without its action,
we would not have had a vaccine
and Russia has already invaded Ukraine.
The
reality is that it is so much more mixed than then
its original party,
the ppe,
the European People's Party,
doesn't want to support her so much
and as a result
Thierry Breton seems to feel growing wings.
He thinks that maybe there would be 1 place to take,
but we don't understand very well
exactly how he hopes to take this place.
Because let's be clear,
the chairmanship of the commission
and evolves normally
at the head of the list of the party that in the European Parliament
comes out on top.
Already,
Ursula Vander-leyenne had been
in a way
propelled by 1 trick shape
since the position was to be held by Manfred Weber.
German Manfred Weber,
who normally
was at the head of the ppe in Strasbourg,
but with the help of Emmanuel Macron.
It is therefore Ursula
who had won the
and we were
explained at the time that it was great
since it was therefore the
Emmanuel Macron's candidate
and that she was going to
serve French interests.
That's not exactly what happened,
we saw it on
debates on taxonomy and the place of nuclear power
for money,
the last strip
was German Minister of Defense,
she was Angela Merkel's minister,
and she did not forget that in the balance of power
between France and Germany,
well decidedly,
France is taking it
very bad.
So,
or by which Breton strip ticket could he
hope to take the place on the band of airliennes ?
Especially since,
the party that could eventually
change your mind and carry it,
is to win you,
so the party of which renaissance is a part
the Macronie.
Except that,
it may be very,
very badly placed at the scale
European.
So there's no chance.
In fact,
Quentin Manfred Weber,
he merged with a tweet to explain that no
only Ursula Vanderlaine was not well placed,
but that Macron himself should
to do anything,
both at the scale of
European Union than on the scale of any
country,
and that neither he nor Olaf Scholz,
given the failures of which.
They were the authors,
we should continue to speak out.
In short,
good atmosphere.
What does this tell us?
It tells us that in fact the
European Union structures
are totally wobbly.
In this kind of game where you didn't choose
between federalism and
Confederation of Nation States,
we find ourselves with states that claim
push candidates for 1 committee in which
states are not supposed to be represented
since let's remember,
the commissioners do not defend the state
which is theirs,
but Europe as a whole.
In short,
who does what for whose interests?
Well,
we don't know.
And in this context,
lavender bear during his term of office
to override its competencies,
whether in politics
international
obviously,
we remember his trip to Israel,
but on Ukraine,
it is just as blatant,
whether it be on the issues
and on everything that actually affects
at the heart of the productive capacity
European,
for under the sale of airlian,
continues to be 1 ideologue of a techno,
of a technocracy that still has not understood
that the European Union
should above all work for its independence.
And behind this absence of political thought,
well,
it is the ego wars that prevail,
as well in Brussels as in Strasbourg,
than in Paris.
And all this is quite appalling